so hello everybody I would like to
present to you Samuel Andrea Samuel is a
composer he's originally from Canada but
he lives in France right now and so he's
been someone I've been following on
YouTube and that I met through Jordan
Peterson as well and has a very good
perception of music a good way of
analyzing music and for me music is
something that I I understand very
intuitively I struggle to to to be able
to analyze it so I'm very curious to
find out more about how the patterns and
music can connect to the other patterns
and manifestations such as in stories
and in images and and in our lives so so
Samuel I'll give you a chance to maybe
introduce yourself a little bit tell us
about your your background in what
you're doing right now okay so well
first of all thank you for the
invitation I'm absolutely thrilled to be
on your channel because I have been
watching your videos and I've been
following what you've been doing for a
while and I find what you're doing is
actually extremely fascinating so I'm
really happy to get a chance to talk to
you so just to present myself briefly
yeah I'm Canadian originally I was born
near Toronto and I moved to France when
I was 22 years old and I've been living
here pretty much my entire adult life at
this point and I came here actually
because I wanted to among other things I
wanted to study at the Paris
Conservatory which is a very good very
good school it's got a very good
composition program and it was a place
that I always was very compelled by the
idea of studying at let's put it that
way so I did that and I studied very
very intensively in France for I guess
about eight years I studied composition
and music analysis oboe music theory I
studied orchestration and acoustics
electro acoustics had a very very
complete education and also in in in
parallel that that whole time I was I
was pursuing my my practice as a
composer so I guess one thing I should
say because I kind of jumped ahead there
was that when I was still living in in
Toronto I was already active as a
composer and as a musician and so that's
something that I always did in parallel
to my my studies and so by the
I graduated from the Paris Conservatory
I was already involved in in quite a lot
of different projects making CDs doing
orchestral pieces and writing chamber
music and that sort of thing so I guess
generally speaking you could say that my
my practice stems out of the the
European the sort of mainly European
tradition of art music I say art music
for lack of a better term
there is really no ideal term to
describe this this sort of music I
suppose I don't like the implication
that other sorts of music are somehow
not art but that carries with it but but
that seems to be at least the term
that's used in in common parlance so
else
I'll stay with that for now and I'm
profoundly obsessed with understanding
the musical phenomenon as deeply as I
can because it's something that is
almost inexhaustibly complex and it's
it's absolutely astounding one of the
more important experiences I had when I
was a student was the analysis courses
that I took and one of the things that
really struck me about that was that
first of all no matter what way you look
at analysis no matter what country
you're studying in or what approach
you're taking there there really aren't
a lot of objective tools for describing
music so that's that's one initial
challenge is that you can have two
people looking at the same piece of
music and they are both you know very
accomplished professionals with a very
good amount of technical baggage and
they they won't necessarily describe the
piece in the same manner so the the way
that you approach the piece will be
different depending on what analytical
tool you bring to bear upon the work
mm-hmm so I found that extremely
interesting and then I started to to
consider all of the different functions
that music has had in different human
societies throughout time and try to
understand what they might have in
common and if there might be certain
archetypal uses or forms of music that
are a temporal that that exists across
the centuries and across cultures
and so those are some of the questions
that I've been thinking about a lot
lately well that I mean that with the
last thing you said I think is is very
interesting and I've been I mean curious
because when you when you look at me
when I approach music when I when I
listen to music the the thing that
really strikes me is on one hand it
seems like in terms of pattern it's
probably the purest form of art because
it's seen it seems like it I mean it is
good it is abstract compared to all the
other types of art because it doesn't
refer directly to to anything else of
course it does suggest things especially
within a culture and within you know
when it's embedded in that in a culture
but the abstraction of it makes me makes
me see like there is something there
seems like there's some I mean it seems
like music is a human Universal it seems
like it's an expression which which
which manifests pattern in almost a pure
way but for some reason I I can't
totally analyze them and so I mean I
would be curious with what you said the
last thing you said I'm curious to hear
maybe what do you feel are some of the
the universal that say that carry
through music through the ages and
through cultures ok so there's there's a
lot to talk about there so the first
thing I would say is regarding the
notion of abstraction and music that's
that's in itself a subject that I find
extremely fascinating because yes it's
certainly true that that music has a
strong abstract component and we think
of certain composers or certain styles
of music as being more abstract than
others which is also an interesting
thing because it implies that there are
different levels of abstraction and that
some some musics might be somehow more
concrete or more manifest or more
immediate somehow in in terms of what
their expression and other musics might
be somehow less immediate so the mute
with the human voice maybe be like the
ground that makes us feel that some
music is let is more grounded let's say
because it seems like at least for the
in the human experience the voice the
the the the tonality is of speaking and
the tonality is an Indian voice our our
most immediate
the most immediate place where we
attribute meaning and sound together or
attribute value to sound let's say I
think that's certainly a big part of it
and I think part of the the idea of this
notion of abstraction and music comes
from the fact that the idea that you
would sit down and listen to a piece of
music as a purely aesthetic experience
in company with a few hundred other
people in a concert hall is
extraordinarily recent in terms of in
terms of human civilization I mean this
is what 200 years old maybe right idea
this idea of the concert per se in other
words a cultural experience that's
detached from any immediate function
mm-hmm I suppose I would put it that way
so almost all music that you can really
think of until extremely recently had
basically one of two functions one was
dance and the other was the the
expression of some kind of devotion or
some some form of ritual or ceremony
mm-hmm so the idea that you would sit
down and listen to a piano sonata for
example and that this would be a sort of
aesthetic experience in an in of itself
without having it be embedded in
something relating to a what would you
call it an overarching cultural practice
that that that in globe's the culture
that you're in this is very very recent
so I think that's probably where the
idea of abstraction comes from if you're
not dancing and you're not singing
then what is it exactly what is the
again the nature of the experience
you're having but even the experience of
dancing is a very strange experience I
mean it even dancing itself it's
difficult to find a a practical use
let's say I mean a building you know a
building holds the rain away you know
images remind you of past events remind
you of things that are not present there
they're a reminder of things that aren't
present at the moment and so other arts
you can kind of right away see with the
ground but even dancing itself there's
something very almost dangerous about
dancing there's something mysterious and
and because we exactly because we don't
exactly know what's happening where when
we're dancing and one thing about
dancing is it allows you to have a
collective experience so I think it has
a very important social aspect right
right it allows people to have a
collective experience in which they
abandon their individual identity and
are subsumed in a mass of something
something greater right so that's why
it's it's so similar to in a way it is
so connected to ritual in that scent
because ritual also has that function
often absolutely right absolutely so
that must be in some manner an
extraordinarily important thing to have
within a society something that allows
people to come together in that in that
sort of very powerful manner so that's
one thing and it also allows you to
transcend I think the on one level the
the limitations especially the temporal
limitations that we are inevitably
subject to in the earthly realm right so
I think I think dance allows you to to
connect with that in a certain manner
and is extraordinarily powerful so that
that would be one thing so to move a
little bit further in the history music
so you talked also about the sort of
abstraction of music one other way of
thinking about it is that it might not
be so much that it's abstract as that
it's it's actually a material in the
sense that you know what is what is
music well first of all it's not a it's
not a commodity it's not a physical
object it's not something that ya buy
and sell it's not something that you can
move from one place to another it's it's
made of air literally and it's it's made
of air waves being being propagated by
you know by something that's setting
them into motion yeah so it's actually
literally spiritual it's literally made
of air it's literally you know the
closest thing maybe that we have to to
to air and we see that like in the in
the Old Testament we have this sense
that that to hear something like to hear
God is a is a is a spiritual experience
whereas to see God is impossible but to
hear God is possible because there's
this I'd this in this relationship
between voice and spirit air breath
the notion of what's immaterial and what
is related to the intellect let's say
it's related to the higher spheres of
being so that's yeah that's interesting
to think about of course yeah I mean
obviously obviously that's not all it is
right because it's it's embedded within
a culture and it has meanings and it's
it has a function and so on but but it
is a very interesting phenomenon from
that from that point of view so so I
well yeah so I think my big question
then I mean regarding the things you
said about the the universal aspects of
our universe alas pecks of music let's
say the the notion of creating a unit of
experience within a people also may be
directing that experience towards
something that's transcendent in the in
the sense of worship but also grounding
in their body I mean the idea of dance
or even procession like you wouldn't
have to be me dance in a more in the way
we we think of it today in a club or
anything but the notion of processing
let's say in a circle or something of
that manner and so would that type of
music the music that is geared towards
those unitive goals or those purposes of
bringing things together would the form
of the music reflect the purpose of the
music like with their with the way you
patterned the music have a link between
between how it's structured and how it
brings people together and does all the
things we mentioned oh yes absolutely in
a very profound way so I can give you a
couple of examples of that if you if you
listen to Saturn Indian music Carnatic
music you'll notice that the the pieces
are often extremely long and they have
very little in the way of contrast in
them so in other words you'll have
approximately the same what would you
say quality from beginning to end now
within that span of time of course
you'll have different people taking
solos and the the relationship between
the performers will change but you don't
have this sort of narrative structure
that you get in a lot of western music
particularly of the past few hundred
years right so or at least if there is a
narrative structure maybe I don't
understand it because I'm not
within that culture but the way it
sounds to me anyway as an outsider is
that it's more contemplative in nature
right I think I think you have you have
musics that are essentially
contemplative that that that can help
you to enter into perhaps a different
state of consciousness or that can slow
time down for you in a certain manner or
just allow you to sink into this
experience in a very profound way and
there are other musics that function
much more analogously to for example a
movie or a story where they're actually
explicitly narrative in a certain sense
in other words you start in place a and
then you end up in place B and you're
there's a sort of displacement that
happens and then once you've ended up in
place B it creates a certain form of
nostalgia because you're no longer where
you started and that creates a tension
and then you have to resolve that
tension somehow and there's all sorts of
ways you can do that but it seems to me
that the types of music that function in
that manner are essentially narrative
mm-hmm so but not all music is narrative
I mean there's there are all sorts of
different just like there are all sorts
of different types of discourse right
you have there's there's four classical
types of discourse you have
argumentation narration description and
exposition and you have you have similar
phenomena and music as well where there
are there are types of music that are
basically you know very static in nature
and they could go on for four hours and
it wouldn't make a difference you know
they could be two hours long or four
hours long and then the nature of the
music wouldn't change yeah okay yeah and
so that type of music because because of
its kind of permanence the permanence
that is underlies it also would would
bring someone to to kind of enter into
that permanence somehow or to to feel
drawn into to to like a contemplative
contemplative spirit I mean the music
that I know a bit more that I've been
more exposed to so is Byzantine music of
course just because of my whole story
and so and and that music there's
something of that seems to be something
of that because they you know they have
this drone that is just this one sound
this kind of bass sound and then on top
of it you almost have this wave that's
kind of going on top of the of this just
one sound
and it also it doesn't seem to have a
narrative in it it doesn't seem to have
a it's almost as if he could start
anywhere it could end anywhere I mean
there is there are melodies in there you
know but the the it they're not as as
explicit let's say as what we would hear
in a pop song right right yeah I mean I
I can't get too specific about things
like Byzantine music for a couple of
reasons one of them is that I'm not I'm
not an expert in the subject and the
other is that I think that things like
that and and they're also you can get
CDs of people interpreting ancient Greek
music for example and things like this
the problem is the farther you go back
if you go back if you go back before the
14th century and even then you're sort
of pushing it but if you go back farther
than that it gets to be extremely
difficult to know really what it sounded
like and how it was played exactly
because it really based on conjecture
because the the idea of music being
something that you can you can encode in
some kind of written notation that is
stable and that can be restituted
hundreds of years later and so on is
really fairly recent so with things that
predate the formation of a relatively
stable type of music notation it's it's
it's very difficult to know exactly how
it was played now you can make a very
good educated guess and you can you can
base your research on extant instruments
and things like this and and paintings
and maybe if there's a written document
or a treatise or something like that
then you can you can derive things from
that but it's hard to be too much more
specific than that but in in terms of
the development of of Western polyphony
and Western art music one thing that I
think is extremely interesting is that
the the very earliest music as far as we
can tell it was chanting it was it was
monadic chanting and the chanting was
simply well had a couple of functions
but I think the most important one was
that an aided memorization of sacred
texts so you have that and then everyone
is singing the same thing in unison and
gradually over time we start introduced
a second voice or a second part and
initially you had something called
organum which is where the two parts are
the same interval apart the whole time
and they're just moving in parallel
motion and so different intervals are
permitted in organum is very is very
strict initially and it was controlled
by the by the church and there was a lot
of rules about what you couldn't could
and couldn't do and gradually it got
more and more complex so there is a
there is a very interesting directional
tendency in western music towards ever
greater complexity and richness of
polyphony and I think that one thing one
thing you can say about about the
Western and art music tradition that I
think makes it distinct from others not
better but distinct is the development
of counterpoint which is really
something that is really very highly
developed in the West right now if you
look at if you look at different musical
cultures there's they tend to focus on
different things and so for example in
sub-saharan African music you have
extraordinarily complex rhythmic
pollutant ease and in in the indian
music that i described earlier you have
extraordinarily sophisticated approach
to melody i mean it's it's absolutely
incredible they have a very large number
of different scales all of which use
different intonation z' they're very
very complex but in indian in in indian
music of that of that sort you basically
don't have pollutant you basically don't
have harmony for that matter you have a
drawing and you have a lot of klein know
western music is is extraordinarily
simple compared to those other musics
from the point of both melody and rhythm
but it has developed counterpoint and
and and this sort of contrapuntal
polyphonic idea that seems to be it's
it's particularity at which i find
actually quite interesting right and
would you see a relationship between
let's say the the development of count
of counterpoint and the development of
this of these let's say these two
tenants in music that play off each
other and i mean i it for me it's hard
not to see that there's a relationship
between the development of Western
thought as well you know the age of
reason and the scientific development
bringing ring
these this kind of dialectic way of
thinking and of seeing the world so I
don't know if you feel like there's a
relationship between those two things
yeah I think I think there definitely is
I mean the the the very nature of of
counterpoint and polyphony is
dialectical so the idea is you have in
order to have a meaningful counterpoint
you need to have an idea a and an idea B
and they need to be contrasted from each
other in some manner and so that's not
enough to make a dialectic though right
in order to have a dialectic you need to
have a and B interact in some manner and
change each other right otherwise you
simply have a duality or an opposition
right that is in fact the direction that
Western music went went into so and it
gets more and more pronounced over time
so things like especially in the
Classical period where it gets extremely
codified and that corresponds with the
with the Age of Enlightenment and you
get this idea of a of an extremely well
laid out form in which you you literally
do have idea a an idea B and they're
presented first separately one after the
other and then you have a development
section in which the two ideas sort of
are played off of each other and CO and
commingle and and change each other and
then at the end you have a synthesis so
and you couldn't have a more sort of
explicit demonstration of enlightenment
ideals I think in that sort of music hmm
that's really interesting and I'm
curious about yeah I'm curious about we
talked about this idea of of how the
form let's say of music and you talked
about the universal that say of music
and so one of the things that I'm
noticing as I look around and I listen
to music today I notice into modern
composers and I listen to just pop music
or whatever I mean it feels like there
aren't there aren't a lot of things that
are trying to think about that unitive
experience let's say they're rather it
seems to have been a break a breakup and
a fragmentation of musical styles and of
musical intentions and so and it's for
me it's hard not to see that as
mirroring a little bit of the of the the
kind of frenetic world in which we live
and so I was wondering if you have some
a few things that to say about that
that idea it's a very interesting thing
and the thing I would say about it is
that there certainly is a progression
and a change over time if you look at if
you look at Western music it's very it's
very clear there are there a different
there are different stylistic periods
that are relatively easy to identify
even though obviously it's it's always
difficult to slot composers into
categories because history isn't that
simple and things were always a lot more
nuanced then then the sort of labels
that are that are created after the fact
by historians and musicologist and so on
but nevertheless there is there is a
demonstrable technical progress and what
I mean by technical progress is that
over time we we became able to do more
things and to do them relatively well
now that that's not to say incidentally
that earlier music is in some manner
crude or or less profound or less
meaningful or less accomplished that's
not the case but the the scope of what
we are able to do has has continued to
get bigger so and also the scope of what
is allowed to be done and what of things
that could conceivably have some form of
cultural meaning or value has gotten
larger as well so that's that's an
interesting thing and that process
happened relatively slowly I would say
over over the course of maybe six
hundred years and then you know with the
with the Industrial Revolution and
moving into the 20th century it it sped
up exponentially and that's certainly
related to the rise of technology into
the profound impact that it's had on
everybody's lives but has also had
another interesting effect a sort of
by-product which is not commonly enough
discussed or understood I think which is
the fact that until relatively recently
the music that would be of most concern
to you would be the music that was in
your immediate environment and that was
being practiced in your in your day and
so composer like Mozart for example had
very little interest in listening to for
example I don't know a sixteenth century
franco Flemish music it just it wouldn't
have occurred to him it just wasn't in
his in his media at all he had a he had
an interest in and an understanding of
Bach for sure but I mean even bajas
relatively close to Mozart they're
separated by by what about fifty years
or something like this so you know
that's that's about as far as it went so
you would be above all concerned with
the music of your time and of the
different stylistic practices that were
dominant wherever you happen to live and
with technology and with especially with
recording technology all of that goes
out the window so it becomes possible to
make permanent documents of anything
that that anyone in the world can listen
to at any time whenever they want and
and so a composer today you know can can
go on the internet and listen to a
recording of almost anything you can
possibly think of mm-hmm so what does
that where does that leave you because
you're not you're not living in the
center of your culture surrounded only
by the artifacts of that culture you're
living in a chaos of potentially
unlimited access to the the totality of
human cultural production yeah yeah I
can see how that would be well I can see
how that would affect the way in which
we perceive music and also the way or I
guess imagine how a composer has to face
I can't ignore this reality let's say
and has to to to to somehow manage it or
deal with it or embrace it somehow so
maybe you can tell us about how what
your strategy has been to kind of
navigating through this ocean of
possibility well okay so the first thing
I'd say about that is that not
everything will manifest itself to you
as being either interesting or
meaningful in fact the vast majority of
it won't and then the other thing is
that even though theoretically I can
listen to anything I want to in practice
I don't write in practice I tend to
listen to the things that are closest to
me and that even in terms of sonority
like in terms of what you you're you
grew up
you know listening to or that that has
formed your ear right you can't you
can't become Chinese all of a sudden in
and hear the way a Chinese person hears
it's not gonna happen absolutely
absolutely so there is there is a
cohesion to cultural identity that's
stronger than I think we realize and we
do have certain habits of listening that
are relatively universally practiced in
the West I would say yeah and I think
that there are nevertheless despite the
apparent chaos of different styles being
practiced today I think that some of
these styles have actually more in
common than we might then we might think
and then the other thing is people are
are strongly conditioned by what we call
taste no taste is actually not a very
precise or a very meaningful term as far
as I'm concerned I'm not actually
altogether sure what it means exactly it
tends to mean the things that that
people sort of cultivate an interest in
and and enjoy listening to but I think
it might actually go a little bit deeper
than that I think that I think that
music is just an incredibly fascinating
phenomenon because you can't really
access the the profound inner core of a
piece of music in a certain sense I'm
not even sure that the composer who
creates it can do that right you know so
the piece actually exists and this is
something I talked about with Jordan
Peterson in the discussion we did on
YouTube the piece actually exists
somewhere between the listener and the
piece itself the meaning of in other
words the meaning of the piece is not
located entirely in the piece itself
it's it's it's somewhere in between
right which is very interesting thing so
you have a certain set of perceptual
filters on and a certain perception that
that that's sort of that governs what
will manifest itself to you as being
meaningful and interesting and I'm not
sure how much you can really do about
that you know you can cultivate an alt
openness and you can cultivate a sense
of curiosity and so on but there may be
limits to that yeah you know yeah you
might just be incapable literally
incapable of perceiving the meaning in
something because your perceptual
faculties are not so
that way you simply won't see it right
well I mean I think if you take the
languages as as a it's an analogy to
that I mean you can you if I listen I
always use this example like it because
I know French in English so if I hear
some Spanish I'll understand something
of it if I hear some German I don't
understand something of it if I hear
Russian I won't understand the words but
I can follow the tonality I can
understand the intentions but when I
hear Mandarin I hear I understand
nothing I just hear noise because I just
admire it's so far away from my
perceptual capacity that it just it's
just I don't hear it I just I just I
can't see the structure in it like I
can't hear the structure that's there in
in those sounds so I imagine it's this
it's similar for music as well I mean I
know that for example for myself when I
listen when I listen to modern composers
I really struggle to listen to hear any
structure I really do end up hearing
what seems to me like a cacophony of
chaotic sounds now I've spoken to music
theorists and I'm sure maybe you'll tell
me the same is that no there is usually
structure in all the pieces that you
hear although for me anyways for myself
it's very difficult to hear it yeah okay
so that's that's a really important
point so let's talk about that so I want
to I want to go back a bit and talk
about Bach for a few minutes because I'm
really preoccupied with BA I think he's
well I don't even need to say anything
about how important he is because it's
kind of obvious but yeah but well it's
just the only fact that if you ask
anybody on the street what they think
classical music is you're probably
thinking about yeah oh yeah they they
have a piece by Bach in their mind or
maybe you know maybe Mozart but probably
Bach I think he's I think Bach is
absolutely central and one interesting
thing I think is that the general public
if you can use such a term because I
don't even know that there is such a
thing is the general public there's
actually a mass of individuals that all
have astonishingly varied listening
habits actually but I would say that the
vast majority of his production is not
very well known you know what we
actually listen to by Bach is maybe five
percent or less of his
production and he spent you know the
bulk of his career writing essentially
liturgical music yeah and it's it's it's
astonishingly amazing music
and the the bulk of that actually he
wrote in the 1720s when he was living in
Leipzig
so the reason I brought up Bach is that
if you were attending the the church
that he was the the contour of in the
1720s in life see then the the the songs
that he was basing his compositions on
because he would always close with a
chorale and the corrals were composed by
Luther right so those those would have
been familiar to everybody in his
congregation they would have been mm-hmm
I don't know if you can say they were
the popular music of his day exactly but
they were certainly they were they were
commonly understood and known and their
their significance was immediately
understood the texts were immediately
understood and so on and that and that
would be movin into every aspect of the
composition and in addition to that Bach
used all sorts of stylistic and
rhetorical devices that were also
commonly understood by everybody who
would have been attending those services
at the time and I mean in the tacks or
in the music itself Oh both but I I
guess I suppose I'm referring more to
the music so in other words though I
don't know what that would mean a
rhetorical what would be a rhetorical
style in music I don't know what that
refer I know what rhetoric is in speech
but what would that be in music well I
think that it's difficult to speak of a
symbol per se in music because there's
very little in music that is stable
enough and simple and direct enough to
have the value of a symbol but you can
speak of rhetoric and rhetoric is
basically a device that you use or a
figure that you use in a piece of music
that has a certain function that is that
is commonly understood it means
something specific it points it points
to something let's put it that way so
it's it's a way of saying something that
has that carries with it a certain
meaning so so we would have those in in
you in movie soundtracks for example
because it seems like there's some
tropes the movies
Trax you know if someone's you know
running up a hill it seems like it's
just always similar music and if
someone's falling down then it's another
kind of music and if it's dark and
dreary then so we have all these tropes
that we immediately you know can
associate with images so is that the
type of thing you're talking about in
terms of rhetoric rhetorical structures
let's say that's it that's it exactly
so if box setting at cantata and the
text is you know hot tears were
streaming down his cheeks there would be
a certain type of music that went with
that you know and you'd have something
very very chromatic can very complicated
to go along with it to indicate
suffering there are there are there are
devices that Bach uses that that
symbolize separation from God and there
are there are rhetorical devices that
symbolize a proximity to the earth
concern a preoccupation with earthly
matters and there are cantatas that that
literally move from one to the other and
there's a dilemma between the two and in
something as simple as a as a chorale so
where Bach is taking popular hymn tune
you know composed by by Luther and and
setting it in four parts is something as
simple as that
there it'll be actually loaded with all
sorts of very sophisticated references
to what's going on in the text but sort
of illustrating it musically and if
we're listening to it today without
knowing anything without understanding
German without knowing anything of the
period without knowing anything about
the stylistic and rhetorical devices
that were being used in that music at
the time you know I'm not saying that we
won't be able to enjoy it because
obviously that's not true but I would
say that a very significant percentage
of what is actually significant in that
music will completely go beyond that
listener hmm because they're not
embedded in that culture because simply
because you're not it's not 1722 and
you're not in Leipzig
right so now you can cultivate a
knowledge of those things and you can
you can you can listen more carefully
and you can read the texts and you can
read a little bit about the period and
you can certainly come to understand it
and it's not you know it's not it's not
even that challenging to understand I
would say if you if you put the time in
the effort
but but you do need to approach it in
that manner as though you are looking at
something that you might not intuitively
be able to access rather than the music
the popular music of today is is
interesting because it's it's made in
order to be instantly understandable by
everybody yeah you know and that that
can function because we are embedded in
that culture and when we're surrounded
by it and so we don't have to think we
don't have to interpret those those
things with anything with something like
baaah which in his music is often
referred to as being universal in some
manner which is an interesting claim I'm
not sure actually that it is universal
and to the extent that you do actually
need to make an effort to go back and
understand the period a little bit if
you want to extract out a larger amount
of the meaning and the significance that
is contained within the music one of my
kind of basic theories about art has
been that the we we talked about this
dialectic one of my theories has been
that the dialectic of art has increased
let's say from the Renaissance but but
more and more faster and faster let's
say into the modern age and and the
dialectic you can see it end in the art
with these opposing movements that that
come to fight each other and then you
know one wins over the other and there's
this this speeding up until let's say
until World War one at least but I one
of the aspects of the dialect that I've
seen is also in this notion of the high
art and the low art let's say because
there seems to be at least now today
there seems to be a rip a total rip
apart between what you would call let's
say art music and wood we commonly call
pop music the you know the the let's say
if you should take the time of Bach or
in the Middle Ages the the basic
cultural music would have been the
liturgy let's say yeah that would have
been the thing that would have been a
musical language that would have united
you know that's all of society from the
king to the peasant and then after that
they
maybe he would have had you know folk
music and dance music for the masses and
then maybe you know you might have had
more elite music or more complex music
for the for the elite but there was
still that that place where things kind
of got together and one of my theories
has been that that there is no longer
that place where the meeting meeting
happens and so we have extremely elitist
music that very a very select few people
listen to and then you have this kind of
varied Reggie pop music that is in a way
very accessible but it's also kind of
like you know eating meeting shovels of
sugar like it doesn't has no sustenance
and and maybe I'd like you to comment on
that but also comment on the fact that
one of the things I've seen on your
YouTube channel channel which is
interesting is that you seem to want one
of the things you seem to want to do is
to find places of contact between those
two worlds and to to show how maybe some
bridges can exist between those two
worlds so that's a really complex
question so I'll let you go for there
from there that's that's a desperately
important problem I think and it's it's
it's it's something that we we can't
survive very much longer without finding
some kind of an approach to so I think
there's there's one thing that I'd like
to say about that which is that we often
confuse the terms popular and the terms
and end the term commercial it's not the
same thing right so commercial art and
commercial culture are not is not the
same thing as popular art in popular
culture and so in other words you can
you can have a piece of art that is that
is grounded in some form of vernacular
expression but that is not mass marketed
and that is not intended to be mass
marketed right and that is in fact only
really appreciated by a relatively small
number of people so and then you can
have you can have mass market art and
and massively what would you say art
that sort of massively saturates the
culture that isn't necessarily grounded
in anything particularly vernacular or
popular right so okay so maybe give me
an example of a second one because the
second one the first one I yeah I
understand
second one is vaguer to me well let's
see it I suppose it
it really depends on where you draw the
line in terms of yeah what what
constitutes you know massive saturation
but I think that you could take
something like a lot of art that was
produced in the interwar period and also
in the after the Second World War so
take his realism for example there's
very interesting thing it actually had a
profound impact on popular culture right
yeah that that's not that's not a
vernacular art by any means but you had
Salvador Dali you know working with Walt
Disney at one point I mean yeah so and I
think that though the ideas that were
contained within surrealism certainly
had a massive effect on the on the
popular culture yeah I think surrealism
definitely won the the fight between the
different movements at the beginning of
the century surrealism definitely won
even until today the way people perceive
art they have a they think that's
something that is creative is something
that is like a Salvador Dali painting
basically right right right yeah so I I
believe profoundly that art needs to be
grounded in some form of vernacular
expression I think that's and I think
that's absolutely essential and the
farther that you get from that I think
that it tends to it wilts and it loses
meaning and it loses power so when I say
vernacular I mean I mean the everyday I
mean things that are are just in our
immediate environment now that doesn't
mean writing pop music necessarily but
it means something that is immediately
manifest in our everyday lives and I do
believe that very strongly but it's not
it's not unfortunately as
straightforward as that as I would like
it to be for all sorts of reasons I mean
the one thing that I think is is making
it extremely challenging is the fact
that you can't really you can't really
have vernacular art on a global scale if
you see what I mean right because
vernacular practices tend to be locally
based and they tend to be located within
you know populations of people that are
small enough that there is some kind of
possible interaction between them mm-hm
and I think that as societies get more
and more complex and and more globalized
and you have people traveling all over
the place
instantaneous transmission of
information it's not clear to me exactly
how you could create a vernacular art in
that sort of environment although it's
not impossible you know your thoughts on
that actually well I mean I think that
in terms of in terms of stories and I
think that in terms of stories that in
terms of image it seems like there are
universals that that kind of cross
through the different the different
patterns let's say and so for me it's
hard to see like I said to talk about
music but for sure in stories when you
when you back back away and you look at
fairy tales and you look at let's say
myths and then you look at stories in
the Bible you really find these patterns
that cross through and so I think that
can become the base of of even an art
that exists today and the same thing in
in a in an image let's say because the
image can be an image of the cosmos and
so let's say really basic things that we
don't think about today but the fact
that the ground is down and the sky is
above and and you know someone lying
down has a certain connotation and
someone standing up has a certain
connotation with their head closer to to
heaven and their feet on the ground
because it's not it's not obvious that
in your everyday life and you're going
through a house that you have that kind
of clear analogy let's say between the
person standing against the background
and that being a kind of vertical
against this heaven and earth but in up
in an image that's in a traditional
image you'll see that you'll see that as
much in an icon as you'll see it in a
Buddhist image or you'll see it in it in
an Indian painting or you know a Persian
miniature and so there are these these
patterns that can exist but like you
said they're grounded in the vernacular
in the sense that they're grounded in
the kind of universal experience of
being a human being so that's maybe
that's how why like I I kind of proposed
at the beginning this idea of the voice
as being a stabilizer let's say or or
like a ground that we all can can we
hear because when I listen
like when I listen to some to
contemporary composers for sure like if
I listen to Stockhausen I I hear such a
range of sounds that are so extreme that
I'd really feel like I'm being ripped
pulled apart because and I and I think I
don't know if that's true but I think
it's because they're so far away from
the human voice that I that I don't
recognize myself in them so by that but
I'm not sure that's what it is because
it's very intuitive so maybe maybe yeah
you can say some things about that yeah
when we talked we talked earlier about
some of the different rhetorical devices
that are used in Bach and I was
referring to the cantatas when I was
talking about that but an interesting
thing is that if you look at his
instrumental works you find
approximately the same level of
referentiality and and rhetorical
devices and and sort of implicit meaning
and things so it's obviously very
difficult to find anything that isn't
it's very difficult to find anything
neutral in that music that doesn't have
some kind of implicit meaning in it and
so if you take a fugue for example and
that the fugues are always held to be in
some manner the most sort of abstract of
the musical genres I suppose because
well actually I don't know actually why
that is make perhaps it's because a few
gives in a particularly directional form
and it's it's a contrapuntal form and
you have four different voices that are
engaging in a dialogue of some kind but
even in even in something like a few if
you take you know one that was written
by Bach he uses dance figures in them
you know the art of the fugue is
supposed to be the apex of musical
complexity and abstraction but it's all
based on dance rhythms and if you if you
pull them apart even even you know even
farther you find that there are all
sorts of little gestures that refer to
certainly the idea of an ace ending line
is is is the idea of moving closer
towards the heavens there's no question
about then there are there are things
that refer to phenomena of stability and
and mobility and foreignness and being
at home and so on and so forth and so I
was reflecting on this and I was
reflecting on it certainly the the
the situation of contemporary music and
trying to trying to understand these
things for myself in terms of where we
might be today and and to what extent
these sorts of devices might still be
able to carry meaning today and that led
me to focus on the question of what
music in fact is and that turns out to
not be a terribly easy question to
answer right because there's always
going to be someone somewhere is going
to say that's not music
yeah or whatever but I think that in
terms of what tends to have the most
meaning for the broadest number of
people there are certain things about
music that it seems to me are
irreducible regardless of culture
regardless of time period regardless of
whatever so the first thing is that
fundamentally I believe music is about
movement so that can be concrete
movement in the form of a dance or it
can be highly abstract movement but that
you have to have the idea of
displacement of we're here and now we're
going here there has to be some some
form of movement and obviously movement
can only exist within the dimension of
time so you have movement which happens
in time and the vehicle for that
displacement is sound and that's about
it
and I can't get much more specific than
within that without shutting out entire
avenues of musical inquiry but I think
that this idea of movement somehow being
the core of the musical experience is
really interesting why would that be so
important you know what what is it about
that that that driving people you know
to two states of ecstasy or to you know
complete obsession or because that
that's ultimately I think that's that's
really what it is so hmm
different types of music different
genres of music affect different types
of movement so some of them are very
regular and pattern oriented and and
predictable in the sense that there's a
recursion of a limit
a number of figures right so baroque
music is is highly repetitive from a
from rhythmic point of view I think
that's one of the reasons why it's so
popular right now in the West and it has
been actually since the 1970s which was
sort of also the dawn of disco so that's
kind of an interesting coincidence but
but Baroque music has a very strongly
rhythmic aspect to it and it's based on
this sort of motor like rhythm that's
very regular in a certain sense and
there are other types of music that that
use movements that are much less
predictable there's still types of
movement but they're not necessarily
pattern based or rather the patterns
might be so complex that you don't
perceive them you can't you can't well
let's say you can't perceive them
directly it doesn't mean because you can
you can perceive something obliquely
right so you in other words you you
encounter a surface quality of something
that was generated by a structure that
you are not able to perceive mm-hmm so
the structure is still operating on your
perception you just can't put a name to
it yeah so well one of the things that
I've been and maybe I can bring in a
little bit of the my dealing with
contemporary art and because I think a
lot of the questions that are you're
asking and that are being asked in music
were questions that are there in
contemporary art because you know the
sky's the limit anything can happen
anything can be done and then you know
different all these different movements
kind of split apart and things go in all
their directions and then the question
of what is art is asked you know again
and again and again what is painting
this is painting dead all these these
questions and it seems like for me when
we talked about the notion of grounding
in vernacular think that my kind of
solution in life has been to find this
ground in the sense that it's it might
be easier for for me because I'm making
objects and so for me to make an object
which will have a function like an
actual practical function in someone's
life to me has been kind of the
discovery of how to solve let's say the
big the big question of our
because I don't have to ask that
question I make an icon you know it's
like if it's as if I'm making a chair
it's like why are you making a chair I'm
making a chair so someone can sit in it
it's very clear and and and and I I
fulfill a real need that a person has
now of course making icons is different
from making chairs because in the icon
there is this whole language of pattern
and of image and of color which reaches
you know into the highly abstract and
the very spiritual and so it's the the
the the solution of kind of going back
into let's say the pre-renaissance world
going back into the medieval mindset has
been for me to find this solution where
the there's a ground the icon is
attached to a tradition to a culture you
know someone puts it in their house they
live with it they they they pray before
it and so it participates in the life
but at the same time I can play the the
same I can ask myself the aesthetic
questions and the questions of form in
the end of of composition that someone
would would have asked themselves in in
a in a painting but I never have to ask
myself like what is art it doesn't I
don't care what art is I know what I'm
doing I'm making this image for this
person or for this church to participate
in their their life and in their liturgy
and so I mean sometime people might say
that it's a cop-out it's possible but at
least for myself it's been like this
this great this grounding of the art
form and at the same time we're reaching
towards the transcendent and so yeah so
maybe you can you can you can offer some
thoughts about that in terms of because
I know some cuz some composers
personally that have that have kind of
taken that route like I I'm I'm in real
part of the the journal that I edit we
have one of our contributors his name is
Yvan moody father Yvan moody he's a
composer who lives in in Portugal and he
he he both makes contemporary music but
also creates liturgical music for
churches and so he has that kind of
grounding in liturgical music and then
and then uses liturgical music as a base
to explore maybe more concert type music
but always comes back to his kind of and
the fact that he is actually a priest
grounds his life and his his his actions
in that that world so yeah so I'll let
you give to your thoughts on that okay
so a couple of things the first is you
talked about the the situation of
contemporary artists in the sense that
anything goes and there is such a wealth
of different practices that are not only
permitted but also that have some kind
of critical discourse around them so
that there's kind of a there's a kind of
a pre-existing slot that they can kind
of fit their work into and it's just a
matter of choosing what particular slot
do you want to aim for I think and I
suppose that's true to a certain extent
but I would say that it's very difficult
to manufacture the quality of
meaningfulness and I think that if that
is not somehow strongly present in your
work and if that's not the quality that
you're that you're aiming for somehow
then you can you know do all of the the
stylistic investigations that you want
to but you'll be producing is
essentially a meaningless object and the
thing about meaningless objects is it's
very easy to produce them and they have
basically little little value right
right they might they might have a
temporary transactional value in the
sense that they might fit into something
that is perceived as having a cultural
value in a given time but that value
might not be very long-lasting so one of
the things that I'm always having to get
back to and when I when I talk to people
about contemporary music and and
certainly I've made this point a few
times in my youtube channel is that you
know the vast majority of it is things
that I would not want to hear twice um
and some of it I wouldn't even want to
want to hear plants right so I'm
sympathetic with with with listeners who
you have that that question when they
come to it and I think that that's
partly just a question of perspective I
think so you know if you were living in
the the 1740s for example and just
attending any random concert of Baroque
music mmm-hmm
the odds would be very low that you
would
would chance upon a timeless masterpiece
mm-hmm right you would you would
probably be hearing the work of a
third-rate composer or played rather
badly that's what you would that would
that would be the average experience
that you would be having if indeed you
were even lucky enough to be in a
position to be able to hear music at all
so there the question of perspective I
think is crucially important because
when we look about when we look upon the
art of previous times obviously there's
been a an entire critical apparatus
that's been brought to bear upon that
art and we've sifted through it and
we've decided as a as a species as a
population this is this is this is
something that has enough significance
that we actually want to spend our
precious time looking at it interpreting
it and preserving it across across
multiple generations and the fact that
that ever happens I think is almost
miraculous you know that the fact that
you have objects that are thousands of
years old that are preserved in museums
that that people actually take the time
to interpret and understand and preserve
it's it's amazing I think that that's is
something extraordinary about about
human nature actually but so that's
that's a process that that it takes a
very long time to come about and so when
we when we think about Byzantine art or
classical art or whatever or romantic
art we're seeing it through the lens of
today and and through the lens of
everything that's been done to it and
and and also through the filter of all
the art that's been lost forever and
that we'll never get to see and and the
the objects that sometimes for
completely coincidental reasons although
obviously not always have been handed
down to us so we're seeing fragments of
a past and we're reconstituting it and
we're trying to understand it from the
vantage point of of today and when you
when you approach contemporary art and
contemporary music and contemporary
culture you don't have that perspective
you are you are in a sea of noise right
and it's potentially unlimited unlimited
right so there must be a hazard to guess
that there are 20,000 active composers
in France alone today
hmm imagine each of them makes ten
pieces a year you know you can it's you
can't keep up with it and even if you
could you wouldn't want to they're not
you know so so they're you it's very
difficult for somebody who's speaking in
general terms about contemporary music
and is sort of trying to wade through it
without already having some kind of idea
in place about what's being done and
what some of the categories of
investigation are and what some of the
different types of music are that have
been done because the odds are you're
going to be confronted with all sorts of
music that maybe isn't going to be
remembered ten years from now or 50
years now and that may have fulfilled a
local function you know in the career of
one artist where they needed to write a
commission or something or they need it
to whatever it write a piece for
whatever reason and and that's the piece
that you're left with and maybe it's
maybe it's a terrible piece maybe it's
no good you know yeah so so we don't we
haven't we haven't experienced that that
filtering process that extracting out of
the of the gold from the garbage and I
and so the the listener who's just going
to any any random sort of particular
music concert who doesn't have a very
broad understanding I would say of what
some of the what some of the the the the
what would you call it the streams are
within that music that would allow you
maybe to make more more rapid
distinctions between what is good and
what isn't good and so on it's gonna
have a really hard time there's no
question there's no corrosion hmm one of
the things like maybe one of the
differences it seems also one of the
differences that in in a in the past or
even in the time of Bach a piece of
music let's say Bach is writing music I
don't know it in terms of Bach but I
know that that leave and maybe before
that art would would be commissioned in
the sense that that someone would ask an
artist to make something for a specific
purpose and so you you you create a
piece of music for this event or you
create a poem in
for this this event you know like the
idea of the the night hoo-hoo-hoo asked
to put a poet to write about the battle
or or something like that and so the the
let's say the even if like even if the
the even if the piece itself doesn't
survive or doesn't move into history at
the point at the time when he was made
it had a participative role in society
like it
it created a moment for this unitive
experience to to to exist let's say
whether it's bringing the court together
or let's say it I mean obviously the
liturgy seems to me like the most
obvious you know a simple example of
that and so I think like my questions
keep kind of coming back to the same to
the same thing but it's like are there
places today are there spaces today
where that type of bringing together can
can happen let's say I mean I gave the
example of I would I would say like the
example of the music that we hear in
movies seems to be one of the places
where that that we we experience music
let's say when you go to the cinema and
you experience music as a group at least
you know you're hundreds of people kind
of you're participating in a story and
it's not and it's not people who are
there to listen to music right they're
not there to listen to music they're
there to for a kind of wider experience
and so but it's still an entertainment
it's entertainment it's not it's not
it's not productive in the sense of of
let's say you know writing a piece for
the coronation of the king or for you
know someone's Bar Mitzvah or you know
something like that like it's not it
doesn't have that that same so maybe I
don't know are there you feel like
they're places today where that that
unitive possibility is still still
exists I think it depends on the size of
the group I think that's a really
important consideration because in in in
in
in the 18th century for example there
would have been what maybe a hundred
people maximum at a at a service like
that and uh and that would have been it
and then those pieces wouldn't have been
played necessarily outside of that
circle they wouldn't have been widely
circulated so there were there were a
small number of composers in the in the
Baroque period who had something
approaching commercial success where
their works were actually published and
and reproduced and you could buy them
and you could play them at home and so
on but that's really something that
happens a little bit later in music
history but most parts so the vast
majority of this music would have been
played once maybe twice and and then put
away and that's it so but it was part of
it it seems like we're heading to that
same direction with your thousands of
composers in France like how many times
can their pieces be played because it
there's a limited amount of space and
time for those I'm sure a lot of them
never actually do get played right
because it seems like that's not it
seems like that's impossible that it
would unless it's done electronically
but for for actually musicians to come
and play these pieces it seems like
there's not enough concert halls in the
in the country to do it oh for sure yeah
the vast majority of them are people
that nobody's ever going to hear about
outside of a very small circle of maybe
the composer and their friends and and
and maybe a few people outside of that
but yeah so the the question of the of
the group size is an interesting one
because if you if you use movie music as
an example so that movies are not always
but can be a form of mass culture right
in the sense that you have millions of
people watching the same movie so that's
that's an extraordinarily recent
phenomenon the idea that you could
produce anything that millions of people
would see almost instant instantaneously
after it after it appears right so using
that as the yardstick for what art
should do I think I'm not implying that
you're doing that but some people do do
that actually there are composers who
feel frustrated because they know that
for example at John Williams has an
audience in the tens of millions right
now and and then they they they measure
themselves against him and of course you
there's no
there's no contest there's there's
there's no way any contemporary composer
is going to have anything like that
degree of cultural penetration so of
course if you use that as your yardstick
then you're going to come up short and
it's going to appear that what you're
doing is hopelessly I was going to say
hunga yeah hopelessly futile and and
just irrelevant by comparison mm-hmm so
I think I'm mostly groping for places
where where art not just music but art
in general can can can play an anchoring
purpose like a because you know the the
ancient the ancient word art like ours
in Latin and in Greek technique he
actually meant to bring things together
and so the the the notion was you know
the art the artisan or the artist
gathers the materia prima and then
brings it together and so that it
becomes like the incarnation of an idea
let's say but I tend to want to see that
in a larger context in the sense that
that's also what I think is least
traditionally what art the role that art
played in a society that it was there to
gather people and to gather communities
into a unitive experience or unitive
identity or or also a unit of turning
towards the transcendent so I think that
that's really what I'm groping for is to
try to see are like is that possible
today like are there places where that
can can happen also because I I it's
also because of my own looking at the
world and seeing what it seems to me
like like the utter fragmentation of our
culture and the end and you know the
polarization also of the of the
political discourse and the polarization
of different segments of society and so
I'm like I'm just looking for places
where we can where we as artists can
participate in somehow creating
community or creating a stable ground
for people to stand on yeah yeah I mean
I think that's an open question I keep
coming back to the same point though
which is that it depends really on
the size of the community because what
you're talking about the idea of
bringing them together you can certainly
do that
in a in a smaller scale community and
and I think that can that can work very
well and it can it can give cohesion to
the group and it can it can it can
produce something that is of let's say
obvious utility and meaning to everybody
I think that men is possible on a large
scale on a global scale which is what a
lot of commercially industrially
produced art can do and not all the
types of art can can achieve that that
level of distribution it's just not it's
not technically feasible it's not
financially feasible and then you're
going to be competing with with
corporations that have the means to to
put things in everybody's face and so on
yeah so and also a lot of the a lot of
the art that is globally that perceived
globally doesn't necessarily have the
purpose of creating unit experience on
the contrary you know like maybe you
know the jingle of a product will be the
music that that it plays over and over
in my mind but its purpose and it's
directed towards getting me to desire
their product it's not there to create a
huge ative experience between between
people right right right exactly so the
other thing that I would say is my
perspective might be slightly different
on that because I live in all sauce and
the sauce is a very interesting region
of France it's what it's the smallest
region of France and it's it's rather
cohesive and you can go in pretty much
any random village in Alsace and you'll
see the same type of architecture you'll
see the same type of decorative arts
you'll hear the same accent you'll have
you know there's there's an
extraordinary cohesion to this society
which which is also a kind of an island
into itself because you know to the east
you have you have the Rhine and that
separates us from Germany and I
shouldn't say us because I'm not all
sation but but I live among I guess
almost all those now
and then and then to the West you have
the Vosges which sort of separates you
from the rest of France and so it's it's
really this little island of people and
they have their own dialect and so I
don't have the sense living here that I
live in a completely fragmented society
that has no Center it doesn't mean I
need to go back to Toronto maybe yeah
yeah right yeah in Toronto in Toronto I
do have that experience so that's it's
it's very very different but my point is
there are parts of the world that I
think you could say that are highly
cohesive but it's it's not the case in
it's not the case in North America and
it's a it's a very strange condition for
sure and I don't know so let's say let's
say they take out Zasa as an example
since that's where you're you're living
and that's where do you see let's say in
terms of music are there styles of music
or or composers or people who are in the
music world that you feel have been able
to kind of tap into the like to into a
disaster and have been able to create
modes of representation or modes of
music that are able to to create that
sense of community or of a unit of
experience yeah I have to say musically
not so much no I haven't really had that
experience so much although one thing
you can say about Alsace is partly
because of the the German influence
Germans are very good at collective
music making that's actually something
that's that's very very strong in their
culture and you know music and in
classical music in particular is is just
an everyday thing that you do in your
home in Germany they have a very very
strong culture with that which isn't so
strong in France for the most part
except in Alsace where you do have that
to a certain degree and and that's
something that I really do appreciate
there's a great deal of music here but I
wouldn't say that it ties in with the
specific local culture and in a
particularly obvious way I don't think
it means that I am very interested in in
folk musics and music that that has some
kind of a
vernacular attachment to to to the
locale like for example I recently went
to leashed inch time on vacation which
is this beautiful little alpine state
between Switzerland and Austria and they
still do yodeling and they've got out
porns Wow and it's so cool and I'm sure
that the the kids of these people are
just like mortified beyond belief that
their parents are doing this kind of
stuff but you know wearing their
traditional costumes and so on but I
just think it's the most beautiful thing
I've ever seen like wow like it's it's
it's the reason that that music exists
it's it's directly tied into the
landscape and they want these wide-open
spaces in these echoing valleys and so
on and yeah you know so it's it's it's
not some it's not some abstract
arbitrary thing where you're you're
doing something in a certain style
because it appeals to it's it's it's
embedded in the very landscape itself
that you live within mm-hmm one of the
things that I've heard people especially
my friends that are from Europe and and
who are spend a lot of time in Europe is
that in in the countries where they
still celebrate let's say certain
festivals where they still have you know
they'll celebrate you st. John the
Baptist day they'll have the bonfires
and although they'll do you know st.
Nicholas Day or they'll have those type
of celebrations seems like where they
still have the parades in the street and
they still have the costumes and all
that then the the folk music is still
living because it's it's really still
part of the the culture like here in
Quebec we have a kind of folk music but
that it has become a music museum
exhibit let's say right we don't have
the festivals anymore we don't have the
the the parades we just have this folk
music and and so we can you know we
you'll you'll have a band that will come
and they'll do folk music for you but it
won't be as if you know you're having a
New Year's New Year's Eve party and your
uncle just take the fiddle out and and
starts to fiddle and and do a jingle
though as we called it you know and so
it seems like art and and it's almost
seems as if people see folk music as
something that necessarily has to be
dead
in the past and something that our
ancestors did well rather than something
that is part of life whereas you know I
have my cousin lives in Switzerland and
he said you know they still do st.
Nicholas and they still have all the
parade and the costumes and that and you
know these these crazy traditions that
the only these little towns know about
and and and they're the Pope music is
still living it seems yeah oh absolutely
absolutely here's here's an interesting
point to consider with with regards to
that so one of the contemporary well not
contemporary but one of the modern
composers that I like quite a lot is a
as a guy named Morton Feldman and I've
done a I did one of the first videos I
did actually was the analysis of one of
his pieces so he was a New Yorker and he
died in 1987 actually but so he was a
yeah this really thick strong New York
accent he was sort of an outrageous guy
and he wrote this very sort of quiet
soft music that's very sort of
minimalistic and very slow moving and so
on and it was perceived by a lot of
people at the time as being rather
esoteric and rather strange music and
but he had a a circle of people around
him that completely understood what he
was trying to do and really appreciated
it and enjoyed it and supported him and
performed his music and were
enthusiastic about it and wrote about it
and talked about it and so on and so
forth and so his his response to people
who who would say to him you know your
musics getting pretty far out there he'd
say well I'm actually writing folk music
I'm writing New York folk music you know
so in other words in the in the circle
of which he was the center or in this
sort of cultural world that he moved in
this was a kind of vernacular art you
know so that's that's kind of an
interesting thing so if if you if you if
you look at it that way then I suppose
you could say that everybody who's not
you know in that circle or is not
familiar with that style of music or is
not a friend of the composer or so on or
whatever you could you could say well
they're being excluded but you could
also say well this is this is his
environment that's that's the culture
that he's living and moving within and
within the boundaries of that culture
you know he's absolutely send
it's it's it's a it's a certain culture
you know that's it's really interesting
because when you as you're speaking out
about that I realized that it seems like
that's probably why also teenagers graph
themselves on to a type of music and
then you know create their identity and
their group you know around music and so
you have gods and punks and whatever
hip-hop people and and they they they
take on let's say you know almost a
uniform and they they they kind of
become that that style maybe not so much
today but at least when I was growing up
no you had punks and gods and and people
would just take a style of music and and
create an identity around it and so it
seems like that's an interesting I
hadn't even thought about that that how
music even pop music can be part of this
this notion of creating these small you
know identities even if they are
somewhat fragmented and limited but
still like it it drives people toward
this unit of experience so that's
something I had not thought about it
well I think I think it's profound human
need to feel that you are that you are a
part of a community a larger community
something larger than your individual
unit or even your family unit I think
that's I think that's just a profound
and possibly an eternal human need and
and art is one of the means by which we
can have that sort of experience so you
know I think that's I think that's
something that's extraordinarily
important and so maybe as we because I
we've been going for a while now I'm
thinking my last question for you will
be how do you see the future music I
mean what do you see coming about let's
say and it's hard because I know it
we're living in a kind of chaotic time
or maybe I would say would you hope for
the muta for the future music maybe
that's a better question what do I hope
for the future of music well I would
hope that for one thing that the well
that's you know that's actually a very
difficult question that's that's a very
difficult question because what I
suppose that one thing that my own hopes
have been tied up with is that I will
get better at making music let's put it
that way my hope it's very difficult for
me to have aspirations for music in
general outs
my own practice right now because it's
too big and it's it's too it's too
complicated and chaotic I would say that
my hope is that I will improve as a
musician in that I will be able to make
works that will that will last longer
than I do and then in in some manner
that will have the ability to to speak
to a lot of different people regardless
of their background that's that's the
aspiration that I have for myself now
obviously that's a very selfish sort of
aspiration as far as music itself I
don't think I don't think music needs my
hopes in particular because there's no
there's no indication that music is a
permanent feature of humanity as far as
I can determine and yeah and we're not
going away it's not going away anytime
soon and I find it actually quite
heartening that see I know a lot of
people who come from rather difficult
circumstances and who somehow managed to
scrape together the money to go to music
school or to take some lessons or to
travel to a different place to go to a
conservatory or something and made
tremendous personal sacrifices in order
to do that and in in some cases I mean
you have to give up everything you know
I know a lot of people who've left their
country and they're not going back and
it's in order to pursue a life and music
in a way that they wouldn't be able to
do where they're from so it's like you
you you leave your family you leave your
country
you leave everything that's close to you
in order to pursue this so what you have
to think hard about why someone you
would do that when you could just stay
at home and and do something else so
obviously you know clearly music has a
kind of extraordinary intensity and an
apple and a force to it that is capable
of obsessing people and I don't I don't
see that that obsession waning anytime
soon let's put it that way and I suppose
I hope that music will will continue to
- let's put it this way I wanted to
remain grounded in in in it in an
awareness of history I think that's
extraordinary
one thing that I can say is that there
is a somewhat concerning trend that I've
seen amongst younger composers where
they don't have much of an understanding
of art history or of the history of
music or anything really beyond maybe a
very very narrow range of repertoire
that they might be familiar with my hope
is that music can be grounded in
practices of the past because you can't
start from nothing it's impossible
you know you what's what you can do is
you you think you're starting from
nothing but what you're actually doing
is you're unconsciously imitating things
yeah but not doing it very well
yeah so would I be aware then right
right so it's it's much better to be
aware of what's being done have a very
developed profound historical
consciousness I think and to use that
grounding to then to then explore that's
what I would hope for because in order
to keep traditions alive I'm very I'm
actually very preoccupied by the notion
of tradition and a few people on YouTube
have described me as an avant-garde
composer and so on which is a label I
actually don't like and I I don't
particularly I don't particularly
identify with because I'm intensely
preoccupied with with the repertoire
that exists already but I what I believe
is that if you love that repertoire
deeply the way to keep it alive is to
add something to it and to to do
something that it hasn't already done
and perhaps or or to because reality is
infinitely complex and our perception is
infinitely complex and the number of
things that you can perceive and the
number of different types of meaning
that can manifest to you I believe is
unlimited and you know I I get up every
day and come to my desk and and you know
I hear things that just make me want to
fall out of my chair they're so exciting
and beautiful and strange and new and
interesting and I hope that experience
for everybody and I hope that we can
move forward with a sense of
understanding the the past of music and
immense cultural treasures that are
uniquely ours that we can that we can
you know that we can have that we can
that we can value and then to move
beyond them also and explore a new
territory that's that's what I hope for
all right well well I'll tell we'll put
the link to to your YouTube channel in
the description so people will be able
to hear some of your compositions and
also hear you speak on both let's say
high art composers but also you analyze
some popular music and so people can can
explore more of your your capacity to
analyze music and so well say it really
helped me to think in direction that I
hadn't thought about so I think that at
least for myself that our conversation
has been as been as been good and
productive for me to to move forward in
my understanding of music so thanks a
lot yeah thank you so much I really
enjoyed it all right if you enjoyed this
content and our exploration of symbolism
get involved I love to read your
comments in the comment section below
please go ahead and share this on social
media to all your friends and also
please consider supporting us
financially on patreon you'll find a
link to the patreon page in the
description below